hello everyone and thanks a lot for
joining so with this click ba title who
needs TBT um I'm going to get started
and talk a little bit about an
introduction first very quickly to the
trade-offs between um commercial AI
models and open ones and with a bit of
discussion of what open means in this
context and I'm going to introduce um
kro which is a python framework for data
pipelines um that we created internally
and is has been open source for a few
years and we're going to be combining
huging phase pre-train models with kro
in the demo session so before I get
started um a couple of things so first
of all the materials of the demo are
already available on GitHub so I'm
sharing the link in the chat in case you
want to have a look I'm going to do the
demo on gitpod
so um people that do want to follow
along uh can do it and I would like to
start by asking people to react with any
emoji that they want how many of you
already knew kedro or have interacted
with kedro be before hearing the name in
the
presentation can you please give me an
emoji all right there's a few thumbs up
there thanks a lot and and who already
knew about hacking phase or has already
been using hacking phase pre-train
models all right many more emojis this
time so I see lots of people have been
uh using it already so mind you that I'm
going to include an very quick
introduction too for a very practical
standpoint so we're not to we're not
going to be discussing um the
architecture of having pH Transformers
and so on but I'm going to kick it off
uh by looking at how you can use them
and before actually assembling them into
a pipeline so with further Ado let's get
started so the agenda for today is first
talking a bit as I said about open
versus commercial models then I'm going
to be introducing kedro our solution to
fight spaghetti Ai and then we're going
to do uh demo so life coding we're going
to be experimenting a little bit then
I'm going to jump uh back to
conclusions so apart from uh the
introduction from before allow me to say
a couple of things about um myself so my
name is Juan Luis Cano I'm originally an
aerospace engineer and self-taught
pythonista I've been already in this
community uh for more than 10 years and
I'm currently working as product manager
at Quantum black which is H kind of like
the AI um division or arm of mckin and
Company I bring my experience in the
open source Community uh of many years
been contributing to P dat uh the Pata
software ecosystem and the Pata meetups
as well and I'm a my journey to become a
CER expert so I hope you can join with
me so first of all the mandatory
introduction I think it's safe to say
that we live in the Golden Age of commer
AI so basically it's never been easier
to use AI poed apps and products thanks
to the offerings of several commercial
companies so this is the recent
announcement of uh the open AI uh apps
based on chpt but of course there are uh
some other companies uh offering easy
access to powerful um GNA models having
said that um
and to go with the CI title h of the
talk um it's not all advantages right
because you're depending on someone
else's API which is good to get things
started quickly but at some point you
might want some flexibility and use uh
the models that you want the way you
want to deploy them and most
specifically these apis are kind of like
blackboxes so there's no way of knowing
how the thing works under the hood so
you might be looking into using some
more uh transparent
alternative and as always there's a open
alternative to commercial AI products
which are open models so I wrote here a
little uh disclaimer because the open
source initiative is still figuring out
what open or open source means in the
context of AI models um in the sense
that we are still figuring out whether
we refer to only the code or also to the
weights of the model the training data
uh clear disclaimer of what's the
architecture of the uh model itself and
so on so broadly speaking abusing the
terminology a little bit we're going to
refer to open models as the one that we
can um download and use
in our computer with different levels of
restrictions in terms of whether we can
use them for commercial purposes or not
and probably the biggest um showcase out
there of open AI models is haing face so
many of you already know it and so Stu
is to say that uh hugging face is a
portal or
Marketplace for pre-trained AI models
and the interesting thing is that
they are uh task specific so for example
if you're looking at computer vision
models you have models for object
detection for depth estimation image
classification and many other things if
looking at natural language processing
you have things like question answering
summarization text classification so the
typical sentiment analysis will fall in
this category and then you have
multimodel models that can do different
things at at the same time justly
speaking so just when I took this uh
screenshot there were over
400,000 different models and this gives
a vast uh ecosystem to choose
from but as always with self-service
open Technologies with great power comes
great responsibility so hosting and
serving your own AI pre-train models is
worth the effort but it requires some
care because you will need lots of
compute power and uh RAM to run these
models and if you're doing fine-tuning
or if you're training your uh models you
will need of course much more um
computational Power and as always you
have to take care of all the governance
keeping the system up in production and
so on and all these caveats are not
different from running any sort of
machine Learning System in production so
I'm going to now introduce kro to see
how we are solving these problems
because in the end this is uh a metaphor
that we often use this is like building
a house so if you have a proper
blueprint a clear construction plan the
house is going to be stable and
similarly if you apply good software
engineering principles to your machine
learning learning data science AI codes
is going to be easy to maintain and
reliable in the
future on the other hand if you don't
have a clear construction plan or if you
don't apply good s engineering
principles to your data science code
then you will end up in something like
this which maybe is good for insights
and for code that you're going to be
thrown away immediately but if this is
something that you will have to make
maintain in the future or your team will
have to inherit or someone else then we
better um apply good architectural
decisions early on otherwise it will be
a little bit of a
pay these again are some um insights
that we've been getting from um clients
users over the years and you're probably
familiar with many of these quotes
things like my code doesn't run run on
another person's machine or everybody
works in different ways or people have
different levels of exposure to supp
engineering best practices and so on so
this is a common problem that we're
observing um across the
industry so long story short the AI
model or choosing the AI model is only
the beginning of the problem it's fine
for experiments but at some point we
will have to work much more to put this
Pro the systems in production and this
is why we created
kro so kro is an an open source
framework uh that applies software
engineering good software engineering
principles to your data science code so
that it makes easier to um transition uh
experiments to production it encourages
harmonious team collaboration and
improves
productivity and it upskills all
collaborator on how to apply uh the
those good over engineering principles
it was created internally at McKenzie in
2017 and then it saw the light as an
open source project in
2019 it's been moderately Su successful
so it has now more than 9,000 GitHub
stars in almost half a million um
monthly downloads and according to arry
e was running more than 15 million
pipelines in
2022 so kedro is is part of the Linux
Foundation Ai and data The Firm donated
it to LF in late 2021 which means that
kro is now a multi-stakeholder project
so McKinzie is now one of the key
stakeholders but not the only ones now
part of the uh technical steering
committee of kedro are McKinzie but also
claypots getting data and soci general
and you can see here on the right some
of of the companies that have adopted
kro big and small some of them are our
clients but many others are not because
that's the nature of Open
Source so this is a um overview of how a
KR project looks like on the left you
have a visual representation of a
directed cyclic graph so what we call a
pipeline there are basically two kinds
of nodes so you have data sets which can
be inputs or outputs of the nodes which
is the other kind and nodes will be
wrappers over normal python functions so
essentially nodes will optionally take
some data sets as inputs and then
produce some other data sets as
outputs and everything will continue
until all the notes have been executed
and the final outputs have been
generated the key idea behind kro is to
decouple where the input output happens
from the code that actually performs the
computation and the transformation so
the Declaration of where the data lives
and how is it going to be loaded and so
on happens in the catalog in the middle
of the screen you have a jaml file
representative of K catalog where each
of the objects that are highlighted are
what we call data sets so data sets are
uh declarative representations of
something that is going to be performing
some loading data from somewhere H or
performing any sort of IO operation as
you can see we decare what's the type so
essentially what kro object is going to
be performing the reading and writing
operations and then some param such as
where is the data set located and where
whether we are applying some version to
it some extra parameters that we need
and so on importantly kro works with
local data sets but also anywhere uh any
other remote URL that you're using for
your data so you see that we're using
local URLs but also if you have an
object storage of any sort or database
or things like that and that's also
going to
work and then on the right you have the
pipeline so the pipeline is defined from
a python function which is essentially a
list of nodes and then the inputs and
outputs of those nodes are going to be
read by kedro and this is what is going
to assemble the graph so basically K
will take each note and see what inputs
or outputs are needed for that and it
will arrange um those nodes so that the
computation happens in the order that it
has to happen and broadly speaking this
is um what kro does but there's much
more to it so kro gives you a
standardized project
template very similar to the cookie cut
data science that H we took as
inspiration some years ago but we've
continued to evolve that over the years
and the result of that is that the
configuration the data the scripts or
notebooks and the source codes are going
to be cleanly separated so it already
gives you a blueprint to start applying
good architecture to your data science
projects then there's the data catalog
so it's the declarative layer that I
just mentioned
before then the notes and pipeline so
essentially what is the computation that
is performed and in what order that
computation
runs there's some experiment tracking uh
capabilities part of kis which is an
official plugin that we develop that
provides uh these visual representations
of the graph we're going to see a very
quick demo in a
moment and all of that can be extended
through the use of hooks so KRA uses the
pluggy hooks framework that um is very
widely adopted in the python ecosystem
in general it's what powers the py test
ecosystem for example and we are
borrowing those ideas to um allow cro
extensibility as well so basically
there's going to be a few hook points
such as before the data set is loaded
after it's loaded before the node is
executed after it's executed and so on
and you're able to plug into any of
those and add some extra processing
extra logging
or connect kro with other systems such
as mlflow for example in fact um we're
going to see um some of the plugins that
are commonly used so essentially kro
covers a wide spectrum of your U data
and machine learning pipelines um needs
but then it uh stops at the deployment
phase so basically um we encourage users
to use some of the available
Integrations to deploy their K project
in some of the existing commercial
platforms or open source
orchestrators this is an overview of
some of the alternatives to kro that um
can be considered the space is very
congested so I'm not going to cover all
of them in depth but it's worth me
mentioning a few of them so kedro is
often compared with TBT for example
which is kind of an um orchestrator for
SQL
Transformations and if your workflow is
very heavily focused on SQL then you
should probably look into that kro also
supports that but uh sending SQL uh
strings and so on and if you want to
deal with data that is nonstructured and
then uh KRA is probably more flexible
than that the kro catalog is very
similar to the intake catalog that uh
was presented yesterday at by data
Global 2 the intake version two and kro
aims to have more flexible and more
symmetric um input and also output um
capabilities so you're able to load and
also write most of the data
sets you also have DBC so data Version
Control that recently has gained some
pipeline definition capabilities as well
um so kraw and to be a little bit
broader than that and then you have all
the common open source orchestrators
such as airflow Argo prefect Cube flow
and many other things so the idea here
is that kro is not a competitor of those
but indeed it can be connected to many
of them and last not best not least um
since I mentioned experiment tracking
before mlflow can also be connected to
kro through the kro ml flow plugin and
if you want to continue using
the experiment tracking capabilities of
it while defining your pipelines in
kro so this is a um quick overview of
the platforms and orchestrators H where
kedro has an existing integration so you
could be deploying kro on airflow Argo
dask if you consider Dusk and
orchestrator Q flow prefects and then in
the commercial platform SES um all the
major ones are represented so you have
the Amazon ecosystem but also Azure data
breaks uio which was a recent
acquisition of uh mckin as well
Snowflake and verx AI which is the
Google offering so we often say that kro
is a right ones deploy everywhere
pipeline
framework long story short you can
consider KRA uh data science development
framework and machine learning
engineering framework but skra doesn't
aim to be a full stack mlops solution so
it will be one piece of the puzzle that
you will have to connect with possibly
other parts it is not an orchestrator so
instead it tries to be orchestrator
agnostic and it's definitely not a
replacement for your data infrastructure
you will need to be running kro
somewhere
else if you want to um know more about
KRA you can check out the website H that
includes several things so you have the
kro blog in which we publish uh
technical blog posts um from time to
time there's the kro demo that shows you
how
kro um displays uh the pipelines all our
documentation is online it's hosted on
read the Dos so you can go and read that
too and we have a slack workspace as
well so if you're looking into joining
then you can definitely do that on
slack. k.org so I'm going to share that
right here as well and that is it for
the introduction so I'm going to be
switching to demo time now and before
that I'm going to very quickly jump to
the Q&A part and to see if there's
something so I see a question that says
the pipeline definition data set inputs
and outputs competition notes ET Etc
look well suited for batch prediction
but how would it work for live
predictions can intermediary data sets
be kept in memory so very good question
indeed um you have the uh option to
define or not the intermediate data sets
and the interesting thing is that if you
leave them
undefined then kro is going to pass them
in memory and never serialize those so
you can fill those gaps and serialize in
intermediate data sets if you are doing
some debugging or something like that
but if you don't do it if you don't do
it they're going to uh be kept only in
memory so I don't see any other question
so I'm going to now share my other
screen so let's go right here all right
should be appearing right now there we
go so as I said these are the material
of the talk so you have here a
full-fledged KR project already and I'm
going to demonstrate in a second how
would you go and create a new one from
scratch but um I'm providing already
some um
computation uh computation notes already
and this is the use case that we're
going to be following so before
explaining this let me go to show some
context so I'm a big user of masteron
now given the um recent evolution of the
social network formerly known as Twitter
which I used to use a lot and Luis via
who is
um one of the key people in tight lift
former director are Wikipedia and very
big open source Advocates uh said this
the other day so essentially he wanted
some tool that grabbed his posts on
Mastodon archive them and then use some
uh scoring or something like that to
summarize those posts and publish some
sort of uh summary on his blog and I
thought this was a super interesting
idea and I was in the middle of uh
preparing this talk already so I asked
like can I use your posts uh as an
experiment and he actually replied that
yes so I wanted to disclose this here
because in good fediverse um way I'm
very mindful of consent so uh we're
going to be temporarily archiving uh L
uh posts but if you're doing this for
yourself it's fine if you're doing this
for others be mindful and ask for
permission right before
that so then with that um premise this
is the architecture that we're going to
follow so I'm going to be extracting
some some uh posts from Mastodon using
the rest API we're going to we're not
going to be defining that from scratch
and so I'm already giving that we're
going to give a quick overview of how
that looks like so essentially I'm using
kro to have my sort of extract and load
pipeline or ETL if you wish I'm storing
that in a fully open source lake house
so I'm using minio which is a S3
compatible um object storage server and
on top of that I'm using the Delta
format that's going to give me nice
query capabilities and then once I have
that data stored I'm going to be using K
to further refine and clean that data
and then I'm going to start using huging
phase pre-train models um to do
that so that is the architecture and now
let's go to
to the actual environment so I'm going
to be using gitpod because because this
gives me a nice temporary um uh place to
perform all of this it's not going to
clog my internet connection and it's uh
going to make very easy to uh get things
uh
started so if you want to uh follow
along I might go a little bit quick and
at times but nonetheless you can click
on the open in gitpod button over here
and then you're going to see a window
like this so you will see that it's
prompting you for some configuration you
can leave everything with the defaults
and then you will hit continue and it's
going to be building a Docker image with
some pre-install dependencies and then
uh launch a vs code like interface for
you so here I am I already have
pre-loaded this to save us some time and
um I already have my minio server
running here in another console so if
you go and open what's in the port
19010 which is uh already running then
you will see something like this so if
you're not familiar this is uh the usual
minio UI um and it's going to allow me
to create some uh initial buckets and so
on so before we can start uh using any
sort of uh pre-train model we're going
to be um loading the data in the first
place so we will get there but first of
all I will need to do some
work going to be going back uh right
here to follow the usual
um structor of KS I'm going to be
creating a new directory here called
notebooks and I'm going to be creating a
new one called First
exploration.
ymb and I'm going to
be using this directly as uh my notebook
of choice so you already see the
directory structor that I was H
mentioning before so I have the
configuration I'm going to be talking
about this in a moment I see that
there's a catalog. jaml here I also have
my project metadata in by project. soml
this is the
um mod replacement for setup. pi if you
haven't seen it yet and then all the
code leaves here inside SRC social
summarizer which is how the project is
named
so there's basically two ways of
interacting with uh K
projects I see one coming in the chat
yes kod is free to use for a number of
hours a month I think you have like in
the order of a few tens of hours every
month so it will be completely free for
the purposes of this
tutorial so as I was saying there's
several ways of interacting with the KR
project so you can do that in the
command line so for example if I do kro
registry list this is going to show what
are the existing pipelines that I
already have these are already
predefined and alternatively I can do
that from an interpreter so that is what
I'm going to do here if I load the kedro
doip python extension and I tell it to
use the current environment that I have
so the recommended
one
this is going to be installing some
extra
dependencies and after a few
moments I should be able to go I'm
seeing some errors here because I still
need to Define some credentials H and so
on but at least it's telling me that
everything is working so what is
happening here under the hoods well I
have uh first of all my catalog which
defines the data sets of my projects so
if I see here there's uh status stable
um data set I have a readon version of
that to perform the ETL Pipeline and
basically this has a type of polar Delta
data sets and I still have to contribute
it to K data sets but you can use it
from here and I'm specifying that this
is going to leave on a S3 like bucket
that's going to be called social
summarizer and the directory is going to
be called statuses and these will
require some credentials that have to do
with how am I loading H my minio data so
essentially I'm going to refer here to
this minio native and before I can do
anything else I need to define those
credentials which are not stored here on
Version Control on purpose
so then I also have optionally some uh
arguments that are going to be used for
writing and so
on so to be able to use this as I said I
will need to Define some credentials so
to keep things tidy I'm going to define
those here in the local credentials. yml
and this is one of the other
philosophies of kro by separating a base
environment that is going to act as a
baseline configuration for everything
thing and the local environment and
following the 12 Factor up philosophy of
separating um configuration and I will
be avoiding accidentally saving any sort
of credentials back to my version
control which can create a security
issue so I'm going to be copying from my
cheat sheets the credentials here but
basically what I have to do is Define
this minio native object and this will
have the this AWS end point
URL that is the Local Host so the one
that you can see right
here this is where minio is running and
then you will also need to do the access
key ID which is minan iio admin you can
see that on the console as well then the
secret access key which is also me your
admin and there's some extra boiler
plates that's needed for this to work so
you have to actually specify a fake
region so I'm writing Here Local Host
this is not actually used this is
because of how the underlying uh data
loading uh function works then I'm going
to be
allowing HTTP so this is going to be
true in quotes
and I will also be adding this
S3
allow
unsave rename so this is also
true and with these credentials I should
already be in a position to reload my K
project so let's try that and now
everything
works so I'm going to be copying this
um excerpt in the chat just in case
everybody anybody's following along and
now that I have my C extension
loaded several variables were injected
into my session so for example I have my
catalog so if I do catalog. list then
you see that I have a number of data
sets defined and these data sets are
exactly the ones that correspond to this
catalog. yml that I was using before
so if I would do here now a catalog.
load statuses
table then this is going to be loading
uh the posts from my S3 bucket but mind
you that I haven't started loading this
data yet so this is going to give an
error and this is going to say um no URL
found blah blah blah so the reason for
this is that the social summarizer
bucket doesn't exist
yet so I'm going to be creating just
that I'm going to create a new bucket
here called social
summarizer and now everything should in
principle work so I'm going to try
running this
again and now you can see that the data
was loaded but what do I have here a
zero by
zero um data frame in fact if you store
this in a variable you will see that the
type of this is a polar data frame if
you're not familiar with pols it's a
fast data frame library with a rust back
ends that you should definitely check it
out but for the rest of the tutorial is
not um important you could be using
pandas
here and so if my Mino bucket is is
empty how do I populate it well I'm
going to be doing that thanks to the
predefined pipeline that's already here
so let's inspect what's in here I have a
data extraction Pipeline and this has a
number of nodes and it has a pipeline as
well I'm going to be installing K of
this so that I can visualize this
pipeline in a graphical way so in the
meantime I'm going to be explaining a
little bit what's going on here so this
pipeline only contains one note and this
note takes us input the raw data coming
from the Mone
API then a readon version of the table
I'm going to be using that um to see
when was uh the data last inserted and
it has a parameter here which is the
absolute mean ID in other words where am
I going to start um loow loing the
data and then if you go to this node
here uh there's a bunch of things
happening so long story short I'm
loading the data from the masteron rest
API and what I did here was defining a
pantic model that contains the fields
that I'm going to be interested in so
things like the ID the creation time and
so on and I'm going to be using that to
validates the Json data so essentially
at the same time that I'm extracting the
Json and I'm passing a Json string that
represents the API response and I'm
returning a list of objects and then
since polars supports pantic I'm going
to be creating a polar data frame from
these dictionaries of objects
and um this is going to be working
immediately now let's focus a little bit
on what's Happening Here this extract
statuses is not performing any IO
there's some objects coming in and
there's a pandas sorry a polar data
frame coming out but I'm not saying
anywhere where the polar data frame is
supposed to be stored or if I'm going to
be keeping it in memory or not because
that is the role of the pipeline so
basically since the output of this pipel
is going to be statuses nodes then I can
go to the catalog and see that um status
is table is a polar Delta Data set so
this is the part that is receiving the
polar data frame produced by the noes
and then it's saving that in a pen mode
and I'm guarding myself against data
loss by uh emphasizing that if this
schema changes H I'm going to raise an
error so how does that look from a
graphical point of view if I do k v this
is going to
launch a web
application
hopefully oh canot
import ah sorry about this because I
will not be able to visualize this
pipeline because K is is um not
compatible with pantic V2 yet so allow
me to show you how this would look like
um in a genetic Pipeline and this is
more or less what we would see so the
data set would be on top and then the
pipelines themselves would be at the
bottom and I could be looking at how the
structure looks like but we're going to
skip that for
now um I'm going to make sure that I
have my requirements uh in place by
running
that and now what I'm going to do is
actually executing my pipeline but for
that I will need some extra parameters
here because I have this absolute main
ID and I'm going to do now a new file
here called
parameters data
extraction yml again I wouldn't want to
commit this to Version Control so I'm
going to store that here and I'm going
to be using this absolute mean ID here
so this is the one uh where I'm going to
start
from and this corresponds to the moment
where Lis gave consent to do this thing
so I'm doing things in the proper way
here and um I could be
um um doing a few other things but
um I'm going to
uninstall kis for a second because this
ruined my carefully crafted dependencies
so there we
go and now after this is done I'm going
to be running this pipeline here so I
can populate my database and after that
I'm going to get to the midy part of the
talk which is using the haging face
models so let's give it a few seconds
to
finishs are already satisfied there we
go so now again I
have my pipeline here it's
annoying
[Music]
um there we go and now I do k run
pipeline data
extraction so if I didn't do any
mistake okay row statuses is not defined
on the catalog okay there's one more
thing that I need to do so I'm going to
cre here the catalog. yml and I'm going
to be defining one more uh data set that
I need that defines actually from where
am I taking um the data so I'm
specifying here that this is a mastodon
statuses data set that it's defined in
the same project that the instance where
this lives is social. cop and that is
the account ID so this is how this would
be looking like
now okay
so let's try
again and now this is loading the data
and I put a limit in the number of
requests so that I don't break anything
and I inserted 200 statuses into my
minio cluster so now if I go to my
object browser you will see that H
inside social summarizer there's this
statuses thing and there's a parket file
that contains my data how do I know well
if I go to data expiration now and if I
load the catalog catalog.
load and then I use this status table
read only
again now you will see that my data
frame is long longer empty so it has 200
rows now and I can see that all the data
was
ingested so to summarize a little bit um
there's the pipeline that uh arranges
the notes the notes perform some
computation but they don't do the input
output themselves and then after run my
pipeline all the data is going to be
stored where it's supposed to be
stored and that is it so now going on
how do I actually use um this data for
something interesting well I'm going to
to run one more pipeline because I have
a data cleaning pipeline here that
performs some
um data cleaning here basically so I'm
stripping out the HTML tags and I'm
replacing some URLs and so on so I'm
going to run now kro
pipeline let's do that again kro
pipeline kro run pipeline data cleaning
and again this is going to be reading
the data from status table and it's
going to load that into statuses clean
which is another uh polar Delta Data set
now if I wanted to explore that I could
do DF
equals statuses clean
instead and this is how it's going to
look like so I have my raw text and a
simplified version of the data model
all right so now all my data is in a
good place and let's start uh processing
that so I'm going to create a new
catalog here that I'm going to be
calling
um catalog
models.
yml and this is going to contain some
definitions of the hacking phas
Transformers that I'm going to use so if
you wanted to do this uh directly from
your notebook and then you will be doing
something like from Transformers
import
Pipeline and then the pipeline function
gets you a model so for example if we
are uh looking to
using um uh fi mask model for natural
language processing tasks then I could
do something like this so pipeline and
then
my model is going to be this one here
that I'm uh copy pasting from my chat
sheet so this is the one that I'm going
to be
using and this will be my fill mask
model and then this is going to perform
some downloads from the hanging face
website and I will have my model here so
this is a and going to call this model
with some text that contains this mask
and this is going to return some uh
results um of what are the expected
values of this
so basically the model thought that to
complete the sentence you could use the
word joke or thread or lot or win this
is trained on tweets actually so it's
appropriate for performance analysis on
the models
and as you can see this is it and I
didn't want to give a deep explanation
of how having phas Transformers work but
to be honest the API is so easy that um
there's not much more to it there's of
course um lots of details around here
and you could be defining your own
tokenizer and and you have to sometimes
be careful of of the input lens and so
on but
the guest of how to use the Transformers
python library is like this so now how
do we use that from a KR pipeline well
in following the philosophy that we were
mentioning before the data sets are the
ones that should perform all the inputs
and outputs and so since instantiating
this pipeline object with this model is
downloading the model from the internet
I'm going to be defining uh data sets
and luckily there are some huging face
data sets already defined in the
development version of K so we can go
and use those so I'm going to call this
fill mask
model this data set will have the type
hugging phase. HF HF trans
former pipeline data set this is the
name that you can find in the kro data
sets documentation and I'm going to be
specifying for reproducibility what is
the task of this model so this will be a
fi mask model and the model name will be
twitter. uh model over there so out the
hood what this is going to do is every
time I load these data sets it's going
to call this pipeline function with
these parameters and it's going to
retrieve the model for me so now that I
changed the catalog I need to reload my
kro
project and now I can do catalog. list
you will see that my fil mask model is
right here so fil mask model will be
catalog.
load fil mask
model this is loading the Transformer
pipeline from kro and now I can do
that exactly the same as before so this
is a and then I include a
mask and this is it it produced mostly
the same results so yoke day thread do
win so this gives me assurance that I'm
actually doing the same thing so you
might be thinking that replacing one
line of code with the other is not a big
deal but this has a couple of advantages
so first of all if I am changing the
model definition because I'm using a
different checkpoint or I'm swapping
what's the FI mask model that I'm going
to use or I'm going to be trying
different ones then I don't need to
change my notebook anymore so now the
notebook is going to refer to the
catalog entry of kedro and this catalog
entry is going to be the one holding the
definition of the data set and that is
the first benefit and the second benefit
is that by turning this into a ketro
data set you now can use the same
Machinery that we used for our data
pipeline for all my machine learning
pipeline AI pipeline whatever you want
to call it so essentially I can use some
nodes that will take some data sets as
inputs these data sets can be actual
data but they can also be huging face
models as you can see and then I will be
performing some some Transformations
here so before I go to the last part of
this demo and transform this to a
pipeline let me go very quickly and see
if there was any extra comment in the
chat okay am was asking a moment ago
does kedro facilitate Data Destruction
so in principle that is um up to you so
if you have uh defined uh data sets that
um you will need to uh remove at some
point and then you can uh write that
part on the uh node function but the
data set is going is only going to take
care of where exactly the data um is
located so there's nothing special in
kro facilitating uh data distraction
distraction you will need to take care
of that yourself
all right so there's no more things so
let's proceed now with assembling this
into a pipeline so we're experimenting
for now so let's stay in the notebook
like interface for a moment while we
figure out what do we have to do
remember that I have my data frame and
this contains uh all the simplified
version of the original data and what
I'm going to do now is is uh trying to
process that um in some fashion so for
example I using this uh F mask model to
complete the sentence but um the reason
why I brought this up in the first place
is because you can trick this model into
adding hashtags for the posts that don't
have it and the fact that I can produce
a list of hashtags means that I can kind
of summarize what topics were covered in
a given week so let's see how would that
work um in practice so for example I
have my um text here so this would be DF
text I'm going to be very quickly uh
loading the first one uh of this so this
is going to be my test
post and this is how it looks like
and as you can see this does not contain
any hashtag or anything like that so now
how can I H do this sort of topic
extraction well I can use this field
mask model so for that I can add at the
end of the
post test post plus and then space
hashtag mask so essentially since the
original model is trained on twits this
is going to be kind of a hacky way of
detecting one some possible hashtags
that could fit into this text and
essentially give me a list of topics so
now if I call fil mask model with test
post and I save the
results now I can get the results and
you see that there are different um
possible hashtags that were added here
so one is ADD there's also Twitter
Twitter AI
RT so and there's uh a few
more um so now the way I can uh proceed
is by keeping only the
result token s Str for every result in
results and results itself is a list
because I'm passing one
single uh
post H sorry I'm doing something silly
here results zero
uh token s
Str oh
actually yeah there we go
so I got confused there H it's actually
returning a list of possible hashtags so
this is what I have here okay and now
that I have a function that I'm happy
with I can actually turn that into a get
hashtags function that receives the post
as a string and possibly the model as a
hugging face Transformer I'm going not
going to fill the um type info of that
and this is going to be returning a list
of strings so what I'm going to be doing
is returning the model called on the
post
plus this mask
here
okay and this is the get hashtags for
one single post and I could apply this
to a set of uh different posts so let's
set this aside for a moment um now um
we'll be able to use this to extract
sort of a list of uh topics for
um the posts that were given but then at
some point I would like to to um be
creating some sort of text that acts as
a summary so to do that I'm going to be
using a different um model and I'm going
to be really handwavy here because
probably there are better models that
you can use but the idea here is to get
to a architecture that we can work with
and I'm going to be using H another
summarization model so going back to my
catalog I'm going to call this
summarizer model this will also have the
type of huging phase Transformer
pipeline data set the task is going to
be
summarization and the model
name is going to be this one here so I'm
using a particular model that I know is
going to work
um uh more or less right so I'm should
be using uh this one
here and let's see how that goes so
again I'm I will need to
reload my K
project now in my catalog. list I have
my summarizer model as one of the
possible data sets so I'm going to save
that as my summarizer so this would be
catalog.
load summarizer model
and this is going to be downloading the
weights already notice that these models
are usually quite big this is one
gigabyte in size and it's not at all the
largest model that you can download so
this goes back to what we were
mentioning before about um being careful
when you're managing AI models like
this so it's downloading some extra
metadata here and I'm already done so
what I'm going to do now again in a very
um hackish way I'm going to be meshing
all these um data sets together sorry
all these posts together and I'm going
to ask the model to kind of summarize um
all of this so I'm going to write my um
prompt and this is going to be a long
string start starting with this is a
list of posts made by
Lis and then I'm going to fill
that
with something here so I'm going to be
joining them by double line and
then join essentially
every post for post and DF
text so let's see if I didn't make any
mistake here how this would look
like okay so this is my list list of
posts this is actually quite uh long so
I'm going to be limiting this a little
bit to the last 20 or something like
that just so it's
manageable and now let's see how this
would look like as pass to the
summarizer so now I do summarizer of of
the
prompt this is not prepared uh
beforehand so anything can happen and
we're going to wait a little bit for the
results to come up going to store that
results is cell
42 and so my
results zero summary text are something
like this so this is list of Po posts
and whether or not this is proper
English that is uh left to be found but
at least it's very clear that H this is
shorter than the initial prompts so
we're working there towards having a
summary of the
content and now that I
have a way of summarizing a list of
posts and a way of detecting topics and
so on we're going to go to the last
stage which is um defining the pipeline
that meshes this together and produces
some sort of report containing this
information I will go back to the chat
for a second because I see a question so
when I invoke k run in my G inst I get
this error missing conf error given
configuration path either does not exist
or is not a valid directly yes this is a
very typical um problem so I did this H
very quickly at the beginning but
essentially there's this local directory
that uh you should have here that is not
part of Version Control on purpose
because it might contain credentials or
other things so what uh you will have to
do to solve that error is to create the
local directory and then you will need
to add H the different configurations
here so the definition of the RW
statuses the credentials that we're
using and uh the minimum ID that we're
going to
use so I'm going to mark that as solved
all right so now let's go to my pipeline
um to my K project and create a pipeline
for this so I could be creating the
files manually but instead I'm going to
do KRA pipeline creates let me do that
again KRA pipeline create and I'm going
to call it
reporting and as you can see there were
a number of
[Music]
um files already created here so if I go
to pipelines reporting there's this
notes. pi and pipeline. Pi so it's
already giving me a template of um what
to do here
and my nodes then are going to be uh two
things so one I'm going to be defining a
function that allows me to uh detect a
list of uh topics and the other one that
gives me the summary so one function is
going to be this one I'm going to
shamelessly copy and paste that here I'm
going to be making some adjustments
because I want this to work on the whole
polar data frame so this would be
aspl and this will be receiving the
whole por data frame here and the model
so we will need to do some things here
and then the other function that I will
have will be the one creating the
summary so I'm going to call it create
summary this again is going to
receive the
data and the
summarizer is going to produce a
string I'm going to be calling
this uh mask
filler just for consistency and being
more
explicit and in the end it's is going to
return the summary so then what I'm
going to do here is um creating this
prompt so again I'm going to copy paste
that from here my prompt will
be
that instead of hard coding the number
of elements uh that I'm going to be
extracting here I'm going to add another
parameter that I'm going to call Max
number
statuses that's going to be an integer
and I'm going to be using this right
here this is again is uh for safety
purposes just in case the input goes uh
too long and for the purpose of this
demo is going to be enough so that is
going to be my prompt then the results
are going to be calling the
summarizer on that prompt and then we
will be returning results zero and then
the name of the key was summary
text there we
go so that is the create summary
function and now I will need to complete
the other function as well so my posts
in plural is going to
be uh
post
uh sorry this should
be DF text and I'm going to be
calling uh converting this to list so if
I do text this is a serious and
then to list gives me a normal python
list and again I'm going to include here
a max number of
statuses there we go so this would be
max number of
statuses and then to
list the results will be The Mask filler
function called on the
posts
actually
H post plus
mask for posting
posts so we fill each of the posts uh
themselves and then I will only be
interested in the list of hashtags so
I'm going to be looking at
get my get hashtag function
that R Returns the token
string so the hashtags
are
[Music]
um H this one's here before I do any
mistake live let me do that um properly
so I'm going to be looking at this this
so my posts are my list of posts and
then my results are the fil mask model
here you see that computer notebooks
tend to grow
quickly really
messy so I'm going to um retrieve those
uh results now this will give me a
list um of of lists of dictionaries
there we
go
so I'm going to be
adding for
every
um hashtag list in
results my
hashtags are going to be ass
set and then
hashtags
add for every hashtag in HT list I will
be
adding hash token
St and now I'm returning
my uh
actual uh outputs so I'm going to be
turning that into a
list okay that was a lot of live coding
and the iron law of Life demos means
that everything can and must go wrong so
I'm going to be um trying out this
function so the good thing is that by
defining my function in the nodes here
as a pure python function I don't need
to do anything special I can um install
install H my own code as uh a dependency
so I will be able to do p install minus
E
dot h just to make sure that everything
is installed
in editable mode and then I will do from
uh social summarizer
pipelines reporting
nodes
import get
hashtags there we go so if I were to
call this then get hashtags receives the
data so that is H DF my fil mask model
as a second part parameter and then I'm
going to use a maximum of 20 parameters
here so let's see if that
works let's give it a few
seconds of course hashtags is not
defined so something that I did wrong
here ah there we
go probably
typos yes good opportunity
to rename this properly
all
right
and I'm going to
be restarting this kernel just in
case and that means that I will need to
load my C
projects load my data that is the clean
data load my fil mask model from
here and now I will be able to import my
function
and run it from here so now I import it
again something wrong with the fil mask
model hold
on fil mask model should be
here okay
and do I have everything let's
see
and of course there's one more typo but
the next one I'm going to do it
live so um essentially I have uh now my
two functions I'm going to create
another one that will be
consolidate report and this is going to
receive my list of
hashtags and
my
summary so now this is going to return a
report that
says you know list of topics and I'm
going to be choosing only the first
ones so hash
tags for example
five and then uh the summary would
be the summary here
and I will return the
report so this looks about right and now
it's the moment to assemble this in a
pipeline so let's do that now I will
need to import a function here and then
from nodes import everything so
consolidate report create summary and
get
hashtags and then I will be defining
each of the individual notes so get
hashtags will
be using
sorry this function and the inputs of
that need to be matched with what the
function expects so this would be the
clean data so
statuses clean my fil mask model that is
defined here so this is fil mask
model and then one parameter that I need
to specify which is the max number
statuses that I need to Define so this
would be PMS Max numbers of statuses I
will Define that in a moment and then
the outputs is going to be hashtags list
and I'm not even going to Define that in
the catalog because it will be passed by
memory so that is one thing then the
other notes will
be um creating the
summary the inputs of that are going to
be
again something like this but instead
I'm going to be using the summarizer
model so I'm going to be using that data
set right
there and the outputs are going to be
the summary
text and finally one more note that
consolidates the report the inputs are
going to be two things so hashtags list
and summary
text and then the outputs will
be report text and this report text I'm
going to Define it in the catalog so I
can uh store it so if I go back to my
catalog I'm going to Define one more
data set here so this will
be um report
text the type of this will be a text
data set which is another one of the
data sets that are defined in data sets
so text data set and the URL for
that is going to be and again my S3
bucket but instead I'm going to be using
this
executive
summary I'm going to add some
credentials here I will need to define
the Min credentials but in a slightly
different way so I'm going to quickly
glaze over that and I'm going to be
adding this version equals through this
will allow me to save different uh
versions of the data set every time I
run the
pipeline so let's do some adjustments
before actually running this I will be
needing to define the credentials in a
slightly different way here because of
how the function works so essentially
I'm giving it NPO URL key and Secret
and instead of repeating those I'm using
the same ones that I was giving right
there
and now it's the moment to see if this
works so let's do k run
pipeline
reporting fingers
crossed oh sorry and I need to Define
one more uh parameter that I haven't
defined yet so parameters reporting will
have Max number of statuses set to
20 so we run it
again so now it's loading the data from
both
places it's running the noes create
summary I'm producing the summary
text now it's running the
it's loading and the fil mask model
running the get hashtags noes here so so
far so good now it just Consolidated the
report and the data should be there so
I'm going to go to the minio console to
my object
browser and you see here that there an
executive summary
txt and essentially here I have my
output so if I preview that well not
really because it's a txt
file this looks something like this so
the list of topics was Twitter s archive
Na and War and the summary was this uh
summary text here so uh something about
um Bitcoin and something about other
things so that was very quick but let's
summarize a little bit what we achieved
here so we have the this reporting
pipeline here that is defined by pure
functions that only take uh python
objects in memory and perform no input
and outputs I did this interactively
going back and forth from The Notebook
like interface to the actual uh python
files as you saw and then I defined this
pipeline here that reuses those
functions here and properly connects all
the inputs with the appropriate outputs
so that I end up with the result that I
want and notice that the outputs that
were not declared in the catalog such as
hashtags list or summary text they are
hold as memory data set which was the
first question that was asked so it was
very appropriate and if I wanted to uh
store them I could add some uh data set
notes but I'm going to leave it
there
so I'm going to stop sharing my
screen and go back for the presentation
one last
time for the
conclusions so there's a lot of extra
things that could be done here and for
example uh I want to extend this to
perform some retrieval a
generation but for that um we need to
introduce some connectors with some
Vector databases and so on that's uh we
haven't done yet so all PO requests
welcome would be nice to deploy this
model as a breast API H or uh some other
form of deployment and um you know this
is producing like a text summary of
sorts but would be nice at some point to
provide some sort of uh dashboard web UI
H and so on
so that was it for now if you uh think
kro can be interesting for you feel more
than welcome to join our slack community
and I'm going to uh just stop there for
any questions that you have so thank you
all very much for your attention
and H feel free to ask anything you
want thank thank you Juan that was a
great presentation excellent
tutorial so as I say we've opened it up
to questions um if anybody has any
questions please put them in the Q&A and
we can take a look at
them sure people are out there still
working a few things there ju so try to
keep most likely I'm going to be sharing
once again uh the materials of the talk
that
um contain all of this the P Global 2023
Branch um doesn't have the reporting um
pipeline the main branch does have it so
if you want to jump straight into it you
can do it um by filling all the
credentials and so
on great and for folks if you think of
something afterwards uh feel free to
join or start a conversation on Discord
um you will find a link to that in our
reception area for pi data
Global and the recording for this
tutorial uh will be available to rewatch
shortly if you want to backtrack and and
follow along through that so um thanks a
lot I see this one question
so um Ahmed says can K detect
dependencies or non- dependencies
between not to execute and parallelize
execution accordingly so yes very good
question uh about parallelization
everything that I did so far uses what
we call the sequential Runner but
there's also a thread Runner that runs
every Noe in a different um uh threat
and there's um parallel Runner as well
that runs every note in a different
process and this allows you to
parallelize and all of this is going to
be contingent on how the nodes
themselves are defined so for debugging
purposes the sequential Runner is right
but if you already have your pipeline
defined and you want to accelerate the
execution yes you can go and parallelize
that very
easy going to hold there a few more
seconds for any F the
questions all right otherwise um I guess
we can uh call it here